[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous on est en direct
juste après t PMP il y a que la vérité
qui compte hein ça c'est un gros
rendez-vous j'adore moi je suis fan
c'est ce que je vais regarder bien sûr
ce soir le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Gabriel Atal a annoncé vouloir
sortir les élèves signalés pour des
faits de radicalisation des
établissements scolaires cette annonce
survient notamment après l'attaque au
couteau d'un lycée à
haras dans un lissaras on le sait avec
un ancien élève inscrit au fichier des
signalements pour la prévention et la
radicalisation à caractère terroriste
mais beaucoup la jugent impossible par
rapport à l'obligation d'instruction
inscrit dans la loi française bon en
tout cas que ce soit possible ou pas
Gabriel hatal va tout faire va tenter
donc de sortir les élèves radicalisés de
l'école êtes-vous d'accord avec lui
regardez cette vidéo et vous nous dites
oui non c'est le débat du jour c'est
parti moi je crois profondément
évidemment au rôle de l'éducation pour
faire reculer la radicalisation moi je
vais travailler avec mon collègue de
l'Intérieur et mon collègue de la
justice à des mesures qui nous
permettent de les sortir de nos
établissements scolaires parce que quand
les enseignants les personnels eux-mêmes
signalent un C des élèves qui
constituent selon eux potentiellement
une menace à raison de menaces qu'ils
ont proféré ou à raison de propos qu'ils
ont tenu ou d'actes qu'ils ont commis je
prendrai toutes les mesures
conservatoires d'exclusion qui sont
nécessaires dès lors que ça protège les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
les élèves les élèves radicalisés euh
bah bah donc sortir ve sortir les élèves
radicalidé de l'école Gabriel Atal
êtes-vous d'accord avec lui euh oui non
pierre gentillet est avec nous merci d'ê
là et PhIP h est avec nous merci merci
d'être là également merci à vous deux
alors qui a ditah tout le monde dit oui
table c'est un truc de fou merci au
revoir oui a priori tout le monde dit
oui même je me suis abstrait du fait que
aujourd'hui la loi ne le permet pas on
est d'accord C on s'abstrait de ça on
dit si jamais ça évolu de le faire voilà
sil veut le faire s qu'elle le permet la
lo en fait le
permet non non y arriver une obligation
d'écleas une obligation d'instruction
d'instruction tes parents peuvent très
bien à partir moment où ils ont les
compétences te font l'école bien s c'est
ce que font les gens qui font le tour du
monde au bateau les gens qui sont trucux
crois-moi ce sera possible donc c'est
pas la peine de tergiver làdessusord moi
ce qui m'a fait basculer c'est le drame
d'aras le drame d'arace c'est que le le
le présumé coupable on va dire le
présumé assassin il était fiché il était
repéré donc on ne peut pas Laer pour moi
comme ça ces gens-là dans le système
scolaire sans rien faire ce n'est plus
possible aujourd'hui il y a 1000 mineurs
qui sont ficher S pour radicalisation et
bien ces 1000 je suis désolé ne peuvent
pas être considérés comme des élèves
comme les autres il faut prendre une
initiative forte pour qu'il ne soit plus
scolarisé avec les autres c'est trop
dangereux cyil donc c'est le danger qui
m'a fait dire oui voil je suis heureux
de voir que tu changes d'avis
puisé
bah si c'est le drame d' race qui me
fait basculer en tous les cas c'est très
bien euh Philippe Henri vous n'êtes pas
d'accord non je dis pas que je suis pas
d'accord euh est-ce qu'il faut enlever
les enfants dangereux de l'école
évidemment que tout le monde répond oui
en fait c'est une question qui qui qui
n'appelle pas un débat la question en
réalité c'est qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
radicaliser c'estàd qu'à partir de quel
moment vous dites qu'un enfant il est
radicalisé comment on détecte le fait
qu'il soit radicalisé c'est-à-dire qu'on
demande aux preuf de PS aux preuf de
techno aux preuf de biologie de dire bah
lui il est radicalisé lui il est pas
radicalisé et puis surtout et c'est la
question essentielle sortir quelqu'un de
l'école il y a pas de problème mais
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait vous dites les
gens vous savez on fait l'éducation à la
maison mais attendez un enfant qui
serait éventuellement radicalisé et
éventuellement dangereux on peut
imaginer que c'est le cercle familial ou
l'entourage qui a conduit à ça donc
évidemment qu'on va pas le remettre dans
l'endroit qui est dangereux donc c'est
quelle solution on trouve et quel moyen
on se donne parce que sortir de l'école
c'est pas la même chose que de dire on
l'enlève de l'établissement scolaire
dans lequel il est et on le remet dans
un contexte qui permettra éventuellement
de le déradicaliser donc en fait ça pose
beaucoup plus de questions que ça
n'apporte de solution de dire on va
sortir les élèves radicalisés ça veut
rien dire en fait la question c'est où
est-ce qu'on les metement la question
c'est où est-ce qu'on les met comment
détecte et comment alors ça j'arrive
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait on sort
tous les enfants qui ont éventuellement
mis une abaille à un jour ou qui les
filles qui ont qui sont voilés ou les
garçons qui se laissent pousser la Bar à
CH non non mais il y a deux choses
premièrement qu'est-ce qu'on appelle un
un enfant enfin en tout cas une personne
radicalisée je je veux juste quand même
rappeler une chose c'est qu'on parle de
combien de personnes on parle de 1000
personnes d'accord 1000 enfants qui
seraient enfin qui seraientisant supposé
ficher radicalisé c'est à la fois peu
sur les 12 millions d'élèves et c'est en
même temps beaucoup pourquoi parce qu'il
y a 5000 fichiers pour radicalisation
islamiste je pense qu'ici personne
autour de la table vous ne voulez mettre
votre enfant dans une classe où il y a
un fichier radicalisé islamiste
maintenant comment est-ce qu'on détecte
ces gens-là alors moi je sais ce qui ce
qui embête et d'ailleurs moi aussi je
dois le dire ça m'embête un petit peu
c'est que ça c'est à l'appréciation de
l'administration de détecter qui est
radicalisé je serais pour effectivement
qu'il y ait un contradictoire je seraai
pour qu'on ait des éléments objectifs
qu'est-ce que serait des éléments
objectifs des propos lappte des propos à
caractère terroriste islamiste on en
voit beaucoup fleurir en ce moment à
l'occasion de ce qui se passe en Israël
on pourrait aussi repérer si ces gens
sont membres et c'est souvent le cas
pour ces fichiers s membres de boucles
télégram de boucles de réseaux sociaux à
caractère terroriste islamiste donc il y
a des éléments qui sont utilisés qui
sont utilisés aujourd'hui par les
services de renseignement donc c'est
possible mais pour autant attention là
c'est un sujet juridique je le dis quand
même mais euh avons-nous les moyens de
le faire juridiquement vous avez l'air
tous ici d'être tous d'accord pour
penser que c'est possible mais en
réalité dans c'est plus compliqué que ça
il y a des traités internationaux il y a
des droits moi je vous le dis hein je
suis d'accord ici avec vous je suis pour
sortir ces enfants d'éco mais mais
attendez la question
est-jourdhui légalement nous pvons moi
je pense pas je pas je pense je P que I
Gabri en réalité il est dans un élément
de communication parce que derrière les
tribunaux annuleront ces expulsions
parce que où est-ce qu'on va mettre ces
gens juste jacqu il y a on en a déjà
parlé il y a déjà des structures de
déradicalisation pour les enfants ou les
familles de ceux qui se sont
engagés au sein de daesh et qui sont
revenus en France donc l'exemple il
existe déjà il y a jamais eu d'image sur
ces jeunes mais c'est un sujet qui a
déjà été traité on sait qu'il y a
quelques dizaines tout au plus quelques
centaines d'enfants qui sont revenus qui
ont passé des années et des années qui
sont partis parfois ils avaient 6 ans 7
ans certains sont nés là on parle de
1000 personnes sur tout le ou je prends
l'exemple puisque vous semble vous
semblez dire qu'il y a un vrai obstacle
juridique et c'est vrai tout ce qu'on a
luus 16 an le montre en tous les cas
jusqu'à 16 ans puisqu'il y a
l'obligation d'enseigner et qu'il y a
des conventions pour ça on est tous
d'accord làdessus mais donc donc
pourquoi ne pas imaginer des structures
spécialisées où il y a un enseignement
possible et donc ça répond à cette
obligation d'enseignement mais où il y a
également la question de la
déradicalisation de ces de ces enfants
suis pour mais je je vous dis et je
maintiens que sur un plan juridique en
l'état de notre droit moi je suis pour
qu'on le change mais je suis prêt à
parier je parie ici que dès l'instant
qu'il y aura des enfants qui seront et
surtout moins de 16 ans qui seront
sortis des établissements scolaires il y
aura des recours et certains recours
aboutiront donc maintenant il faut qu'on
se donne les moyens moi je suis pour
qu'on aille jusque là je page fait
énormément parler ces deux élèves de CE2
qui ont été stoppés ce lundi dans une
école de Nice alors qu'ils organiser une
prière musulmane regardez est-ce que
vous êtes choqué ou pas par ça ou est-ce
que vous trouvez que c'est démesuré la
réaction qu' a eu choqué ou pas choqué
dites-nous dans l'enceinte d'une école
niceoise deux élèves de CE2 ont organisé
une prière musulmane le maire de Nice
Christian estrosie et la rectrice de
l'académie Natacha Chiko ont dénoncé des
atteintes au principe de laïcité
Christian estrzi a demandé à la
directrice de l'école